hello everyone one of the most amazing
attacking games happen yesterday it was
the 2017 speed chess championship on
chess calm
it was the semi-finals and Alexander
Greece Chuck is playing against Maxime
Varsha holograph and well it was quite
an amazing game one of the one of the
best attacking games have seen in in a
long time a good issue had the white
pieces and he played efore and will of
course well his response to e4 is known
it's the Sicilian defense and what grace
Chuck it seems he avoided the main line
he played Knight to c3 the clawed
Sicilian probably well MVL is known to
be a Sicilian expert so this is quite
understandable d6
and F for the Grand Prix variation
Knight to c6 Knight to f3 g6 Bishop to
c4 Bishop to g7 Greece to castles we
have b6 and the d4 immediately opening
up the center as the black king is still
in the middle of the board here MBL play
tonight captures on d4 winning a pawn
would seek after sandy for doesn't
really do anything for black as after
Knight to be 5 white can always well
just recapture the pawn but there was
always something better if a black even
tries to defend this pawn his King is
still in the center of the board this
wouldn't be very safe so after d4 NBL
responded with knife capture son before
and we had Bishop to e3 Knight captured
on f3 Queen captures on f3 and Knight to
e7 Greece Chu goes for rook a to d1 now
threatening the Bishop captures on c5
but nvl decided to let this pawn go as
he is up a pawn so he decided to castle
instead Bishop captures not see if I was
played and Queen to c7 now with Bishop
captures and e6 Queen captures on c4 but
this is what the gray strip does he
plays Bishop captures on d6 Queen
captures a bishop on c4 and the bishop
captures on e7
we have rook now to e8 attacking this
bishop on e7
and here we have an extreme and extreme
move this is this is this is something
else
Grisha plays d5 he invites MVL to
capture this Bishop on e7 to go for some
sort of an attack although nothing is
well you don't really have anything
straight away from the attack so it's
it's a beautiful piece sacrifice also
with d5 he's locking this Bishop on g7
he it's not really that's wrong of a
piece so I mean all of course captures
this Bishop rook captures on e7 and we
have a rook to d8 with check this has to
be defended Bishop to Bishop to f8 is
pretty much the only move and here we
have Knight to d4 Knight to e4 sorry
threatening knife to f6 check and the
well this would be very dangerous so
King to g7 is played not allowing any
checks 92126 nevertheless and well this
is the critical position in the attack
it's very hard to find a good move for
black here MVL played Queen captures on
c2 and this allowed an unstoppable an
unstoppable attack but the only move
that actually can save mvl is the rook
to d7 you have to give up this rook
temporarily because after knife chapter
77 you play Bishop to e7 now attacking
this rook and this rook has nowhere to
go if rook to e8 displayed to attack the
bishop within Queen to d4 check and
after king h1 you simply pick up the
night with queen capture 77 but as this
was a blitz game our resource like this
isn't isn't very easy to find so after
Knight to f6
mvl played Queen captures on c2 and this
allows Grace Chuck to really go all out
he plays Queen to h3 and are threatening
Queen captures on h7 with checkmate
so h5 must be played now Queen to g3 the
threat is Knight captures on h5 as now
this Jeep on is pinned Queen to a5 only
move to stop this and well this is a
really great position it's a great
moment in the game I watched this game
live and
and Daniel wrench were considering how
rook to c1 was really really a strong
move it really leaves black without any
options he can't develop would be six
Bishop to be seven this Bishop is going
to fall but after this Queen to a5 move
grace Chuck played an even more
outstanding more he played rook to d1
and they nobody really understood what
the idea behind rook to d1 is and I mean
now you're you're allowing b6 and Bishop
to b7 I allowed this why not play rook
to C 1
so MVL I immediately played b6 hoping to
develop this light square bishop but
then Grace Chuck showed his true
intention he played rook captures on f8
and well you can't really capture this
rook and BL did capture because there is
no immediate well I mean there is but
it's not that easy to see it he captured
the rook and the grace chip played rook
to the eighth with check King to g7 was
played and now rook to g8 with Czech and
we all play King to h6 only move and out
comes grease Chuck's a brilliant idea
he plays h4 and what in this position
and we all resigned the game as there is
no defense against Queen to g5 I would
have removed black plays for example
Bishop to e6 doesn't really matter
Queen to g5 wins the game immediately
Queen captures and g5 only move and H
captures on g5 with checkmate it's it's
announced outstanding checkmate and and
the brilliant attack a brilliant piece
sacrifice with this d5 idea and well for
a blitz go for a blitz game it's it's
just amazing how grace Chuck found all
this and such in such short time so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
this were these word I mean these were
the semi-finals
the district is waiting for the winner
who will win Magnus Carlsen is playing
against Wesley so in November and then
he will play against the winner of that
match will play against grace choke and
in the semi-finals and then we'll have
the finals depending
who who wins on the other side of the
schedule table so yeah that's it I do
hope you enjoyed the game as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon